this video is dedicated to two different
types of people one you're either not an
entrepreneur and I'm gonna make you
chase why you ought to become an
entrepreneur and two you may be an
entrepreneur and you forgot why you
became an entrepreneur in the first
place so let's get right into it 26
reasons why you ought to become an
entrepreneur number one let me take
another one in no specific order number
one is the unknown there is some
exciting about becoming an entrepreneur
because every day there's an unknown
what's going to happen with this what if
this takes place what if that takes
place and it needs to prepare you for a
certain thing you need to bring out a
certain side of you that you never seen
before that's the unknown the unknown
part brings that a certain unpredictable
side of you that you can only see if
you're not renewing employee you know
it's pretty much a we're doing this
unless if you're in an environment
that's constantly grown for the most
part most people it's everyday it's the
same exact thing so number one is
unknown number two constantly having to
meet a newer better version of yourself
so think about this think about you're
30 years old watching this if you're an
entrepreneur and you don't recreate
yourself every 90 days you ain't gonna
make it as an entrepreneur you're gonna
get crushed by somebody else if you
ain't constant problem proving yourself
you're gonna get hammered by somebody
else so the great thing about becoming
an entrepreneur and you're 30 imagine
where you're gonna be at 31 that's
exciting
imagine we're gonna be at 32 at 33 34 my
got 40 45 48 50 then how am I gonna be
at 50 you may be watching this you're 17
how will you be at 22
how will you be at 27 at 29 that is the
exciting part I've seen a better version
of you and so it's like I'm it's like an
award-winning movie you're watching that
every time I'm gonna be the new
character but the entire character is
who you
number-three freedom you have a freedom
to do a lot of different things
freedom is a big part of it most people
don't have the freedom that they want
when you have a job the freedom could be
what as much money as you want to make
freedom to travel see the world freedom
to where you want to live zip code all
this other stuff
its freedom number
or it's the greatest game you'll ever
play so if you're watching it's the same
I love video games yeah for something
but I love video games if you want to I
love board games you know what were some
of the board games we played Monopoly
what else is there
chess or or what's the life the board
game wasn't there yet life or clue was
another node 1 is clue or what Monopoly
I mean these things are games because
it's like how can I win in this game
becoming an entrepreneur is the greatest
board game you'll ever play let me tell
you there's not a better board game than
being and I'm mark my words there's not
a better board game than becoming an
entrepreneur because it's a game you're
playing there's a score there's
excitement there's strategies there's
team partnership collaboration it's it's
exciting when you when you're running a
game for the rest of your life and can
you imagine you play a game for 50 more
years that's becoming an entrepreneur 5
no politics when I say no politics is
look no matter what you ever do there's
going to be some level of politics but
in the world of business as an
entrepreneur if you kind of want to do
what you want to do there's a lot of
things you can do have flexibility now
is it smart to kind of go around and
telling everybody off all the time of
course not then you're not creating
synergistic relationships but you don't
have the politics of I better do this
before I move up and I have to kiss his
butt before I move up there is none of
that going on in the world of
entrepreneurship number six get paid
what you're worth what do you want to
make you're gonna get paid by the way if
you're not trippin on you're saying well
you not only make $30,000 you as an
entrepreneur that's what you're worth
today based on your effort improvement
progress innovation thinking creativity
work ethic all of that stuff if you're
an entrepreneur making 2 million dollars
a year right now guess what you're worth
you are worth 2 million dollars a year
as an entrepreneur number seven
you're fireproof what's fireproof no one
can fire you the only people that can
fire you're your customers and your
employees but everybody else no one can
come and say you're fired today
no you can't get fired there's no one
that can fire you you're fireproof
number eight happiness generally you
meet bitter people bitter people are
simply coming from a state of not
improving if somebody doesn't improve
they're bitter you mean happy
they're typically improving and they're
typically creating bitter people don't
improve them create happy people improve
and create there's a certain level of
how you get when you're improving and
you're creating happiness comes from
that you know a lot of people say my
gosh why are entrepreneurs so fired up
and energized you go try to create and
improve and see what happens to you
you'll be very happy as well yourself
number nine you don't have to be a
genius you know you do not have to be a
genius to make it as an entrepreneur why
you can always recruit geniuses you can
always recruit people that are 10 times
smarter than you
sometimes in the corporate world you
have to be a genius to move up or you
have to do a lot of things to move up
and all these fancy Yogi's that you
don't have to worry about as an
entrepreneur you can simply very be a
very good recruiter of genius minds and
then that helps you grow as an
entrepreneur next number 10 it's the
closest thing you'll play the sports so
if you love sports and you're a person
that loves your football or baseball or
basketball or swimming or soccer or
hockey whatever it is and you played
high school football or high school
basketball College maybe or even
professional for some of you guys that
are pro sports that you follow me and we
talk about all the time and afterwards
if you play competitive sports and that
part is missing men it's as if a part of
you died literally it's as if a part of
you died if you played sports and
there's no more sports of competition
it's the sports of business similar
things takes in place practice putting
the team together competition on leaders
both stats showing up early leaving late
hitting the weights all of that is
combined together because the closest
thing you played two sports number
eleven creativity you you can use your
creativity in so many different ways
strategies marketing creating an edge
product you know events or sales
contests trip so many different ways you
can use your creativity number 12
community community you're part of a
community you're part of a community of
other entrepreneurs you speak a certain
language that other entrepreneurs speak
you haven't gone to a certain city or a
certain country and they speak of
different language you kind of look at
it by like man I wish I spoke their
language
when to entrepreneurs speak and other
people are not entrepreneurs everybody
says I spoke the language of
entrepreneurship man we speak a very
nice unique language that's sexy ain't
it it's sexy when you become an
entrepreneur you know it's part of a
certain community that we speak a
complete different language number
thirteen contribution you are
contributing to society you are creating
jobs you are helping people advance on
life you are having a design better
products are better than the competitors
so customers are happy contribution you
help nonprofit organizations you have
people that need help with contribution
it's very fulfilling when you're
contributing number fourteen control you
can control in many different ways you
can control in time you can control in
freedom you can control in so many
different ways you have control over
number 15 you know as an entrepreneur
one of the reasons why you ought to be
an entrepreneur if you're a little bit
weird if you're watching us and little
bit weird you're off you're crazy you
know you're you're maybe people have
said you have a DD or ADHD or hypomanic
or manic or whatever it is you're little
bit off you're weird you're different
than anybody else do something you got
like three four different personalities
it's like perfect for you just so you
realize in the world of business that is
a compliment in a world of corporate
you're weird in the world of business
you're a genius
Wow look at this mind any kind of like
man I feel like I felt like a fool and I
feel like I'm partying with a bunch of
the weird people and I'm an entrepreneur
I finally found a group I belong to next
dress attire I had somebody that came to
my office the other day and from an
executive from a major insurance company
says oh wow so you're just casually -
that's you know this is my tire
I love capitalism I am an entrepreneur
this is how I dress and every once in a
while I put a suit for a special
occasion and today doesn't happen to be
a special occasion
why because I'm an entrepreneur this is
how I like to dress this is how I dress
now my causes a stack with a bunch of
suits I like to dress like this as an
entrepreneur because I can't dress like
this as an entrepreneur as long as I'm
professional I know what I'm talking
about people still do business with me
next to have a voice you can have a
voice you can have a voice in your
community
you know you can have a voice in your
state you can have a voice because
you're talking in an area where you know
what you're talking about as an
entrepreneur you have a bigger platform
you have a bigger megaphone you have a
voice number 18 changing the world
there's some special about changing the
world let me tell you something some
people say my gosh you know you really
think you can change the world many of
you you're dreaming you sound like a six
year old kid watching some of these
fantasy movies you can't change the
world this isn't avatar the movie they
say no cartoon you ain't he-man or
transformers or spider-man or you know
Superman or Batman or all this other
stuff well let me tell you something
there are a lot of superheroes in the
world except they don't have a cape on
they're entrepreneurs they're
entrepreneurs and they're changing the
world in many different ways
Bill Gates is a hero he changed the
world Steve Jobs changed the world Bezos
changed the world
Walton changed the world mas changed the
world
Rockefeller changed the world so many
people change the world as an
entrepreneur and not only with the jobs
they create and a business they created
on the side given to charity maybe not
everybody but a lot of them give so much
money to charity look at Buffett right
now the kind of money wants to give
charity look at what Gates wants to he
wants to cure so many different viruses
around the world because it's his
mission is worth 60 70 80 billion bucks
changing the world baby it's such an
incredible high to know they can change
the world number 19 I guess I got a
message I got a message earlier today I
don't know if it's like a current thing
or whatever it is people message me say
Pat what do you think about marijuana as
a form of therapy so what do you think
about LSD or cocaine or ecstasy because
it helps with creativity how do I
describe this in the nicest way possible
because we have a lot of young people
that follow me let me explain it to you
this way why do people use drugs people
use drugs because they get what either
they want to escape their existing life
that they don't like and using this drug
takes me to a complete different state
so I can escape the life that I don't
like or I can use the idea of me
I smoke weed I come up with some
incredible ideas because I'm high and
it's just it taps into my creativity etc
etc etc and you know studies have shown
that there's nothing wrong with smoking
weed always this argument that happens
it okay
weed is a natural thing to use no
problem you want to make that case
phenomenal you want to make that case
and you're high when you smoke weed for
30 minutes or an hour or you do power
all these other things and the greatest
highs in life our natural highs that
last 10 years can you imagine being high
for 10 years that's what it is when
you're an entrepreneur you're high for
life
I'm literally I am high half the time I
have all voice hi I'm currently hot you
just don't know it my eyes gonna turn
red I don't start seeing like when you
do shrooms and I'm seeing like
butterflies and I see like a flying
dinosaur like a unicorn er what was that
one movie neverending story with that
white dog that looks like a little
- except you nobody never anything Stolp
but literally when I tell you this I am
high like you wouldn't believe
I am high like you wouldn't believe
except I don't use drugs naturally at
somebody asked me today they said Pat
how come you don't drink coffee because
you know I don't drink coffee ice it's
very easy the reason why I don't drink
coffee is why would a 20 year old kid
use Viagra wait am I don't get us a 20
year-old boy doesn't need viagra maybe a
viagra use in your 50s in your 60s but
at 20 years o to use viagra
why am I gonna drink coffee in my 20s
and my 30s my coffee should be exercise
I'll drink coffee my 50s and my sixties
I don't need coffee right now I don't
need to because it's natural hi baby I
want to be naturally high as an
entrepreneur you have a lot of natural
highs xx boredom you're never gonna be
bored you ain't never gonna be bored you
got to be ready all the time because
there's a lot of surprises you don't
have time to be bored as an entrepreneur
number 21
age doesn't matter you're 21 it's okay
you're 16 all good you're you're 38 fine
73 totally fine 82 cool age doesn't
matter
the world of entrepreneurship let me
explain to why that's so important I get
so many questions Pat what do I do
I was a former executive for Sony making
400 grand a year and I was with them for
20 years and now nobody wants to hire me
I'm 62 years old everywhere I go I hear
the famous thing which is what you are
overqualified then I get comments from
people on 15 years old my mom and dad
don't believe I can do this and I
thought that all this other stuff what
do I do
world of entrepreneurship your age
doesn't matter your age doesn't matter
at all it's zero it has nothing to do
with your age as an entrepreneur we did
a video last week that said what was the
time of the video that was it out of the
video last week it was what the what age
does age matter as an entrepreneur if
you have a watch it you can go watch it
from last week that's age matter as an
entrepreneur NH has nothing to do in the
world of entrepreneurship number 22 a
legacy you know legacy is powerful when
you die and this thing is done and your
spirit goes wherever it's going to go
with you believe there's a heaven
reincarnation nothing you're done you
know it replaces into an animal or plant
out on whatever you think whatever your
belief system is on that um there's
nothing like your kids saying you know
my mom my dad left a legacy for us that
we're gonna be talking about forever it
come there's nothing like your grandkids
saying one day I want to be like you you
I'm gonna be like you you know what that
feels like it's priceless
a legacy baby there's nothing like your
community saying man this gal change
this entire city this dude
changed the entire world because their
legacy let you left behind you may have
only lived 80 years but your legacy is
gonna live to 3,000 years your legacy
doesn't have an age your legacy outlives
your age of how many years you live
that's the legacy man history books like
this why not chase that that's
entrepreneurship for you number 23
recognition if you like recognition
competing all that said there's a
leaders world on world launch producers
you're going to be recognized quite a
lot number 24 no degrees needed I don't
have a degree I don't have a 40
degree I don't have a two-year degree
and I just got accepted to University
I'll be now since you got your
short-term what took place stay tuned
for that's going to shock everybody and
what happened I told myself if I ever go
to college or university I will only go
to one that accepts me and I'll be
announcing that here in the next few on
which one it is and you'll hear about
that here shortly but no degrees needed
I don't have a four-year I don't have a
two-year I don't have any of that stuff
none of those things you don't need a
degree as an entrepreneur 25 you develop
unique muscles let me tell you what I
mean by developing unique muscles in the
world of bodybuilding if I grab a
dumbbell and I curl what am i building
biceps if I grab you know a crowbar and
I do nose crushers right if I do I'm
developing triceps if I grab a
benchpress and I'm doing bench press I'm
develop on my chest if I do Show press
I'm doing shows it's a five you know
traps I'm doing you know for my working
on my traps if I do squats legs no
matter how much you work at all this
muscle there are certain muscles you can
work unless if you swim there is no gym
there's no machine at the gym that works
the muscles that your body works if you
swim there are no machines at the gym
that can develop your muscles that
swimming can develop what does this mean
you ever seen a swimmer's body you ever
see Michael Phelps what he looks like
the body forms in a complete different
way because there's a muscle you develop
when you swim there you can't hit with
the weights right so you same power what
does that have to do with anything so
you have so many gifts and talents you
don't ever know about most people never
see it unless if you become an
entrepreneur you will never know about
it when you become an entrepreneur you
all of a sudden say I never knew I was
good in this this this but I can't write
it and say that's this strength and
that's that gift the only way you'll
know about that is if you become an
entrepreneur can you imagine living 80
years and you die never find out about
those two three gifts that you have that
can make an impact in the world why
would you want to sacrifice your
capacity what would you want to
sacrifice your capacity is it really
worth it
I don't think so will you become an
entrepreneur you'll find out about your
unique gifts that you have and last but
not least location you can be an
entrepreneur from any part of the world
it doesn't matter where you want to be I
used to live in LA decided to move my
office to Dallas Texas now we're
headquartered out of Dallas Texas it's
all good I don't have to be in LA I can
be out of here I talked to uh who was a
John Lee Dumas
this morning when we were doing his
podcast today John Lee Dumas
entrepreneur on fire and he told me he's
out over Puerto Rico you know he was
telling me all these things on why he
just moved to Puerto Rico in May which
is fascinating for him to move to Puerto
Rico he can do that he's an entrepreneur
there's so many where do you want to
live uh Sandow you want to live in New
York City could do it you want to live
in Miami you can do you want to run out
of Austin you want to run out of San
Fran sento is it what do you want to run
out of you could do it as an
entrepreneur because there's business to
be done pretty much anywhere in the
world so with that being said listen
people often ask me they say Pat man do
you always wear those shirts let me
explain to you I can't stand it when I
wake up in the morning or the night
before and have to pick out my on my
suit of my outfit there's nothing like
putting a suit on I love putting the
suit on I mean I love wearing a suit I
love weren't suits you couldn't force me
to wear suit I love wearing suits
there's some nice about wearing a nice
suit that fits you like a glove that's
tailored suit there just it feels so
good when you wear a nice suit right
it's fascinating when you wear a nice
suit but there's a uniform for
entrepreneurs and that is called I am an
entrepreneur shirt if you see me in the
mall you see me in the airport you see
me on a plane you see me speaking you
see me anywhere I'm wearing a shirt that
says I am an entrepreneur which looks
like this Michelangelo let's just put a
picture up there so they can see it or I
were a shirt that says I love capitalism
entrepreneurship free enterprise
capitalism it's all the same thing you
can't be an entrepreneur nothing about
capitalism it's just it's an oxygen it
doesn't go - it's the same exact thing
entrepreneurship capitalism free
enterprise is the same thing if you
don't like the word capitalism maybe
it's because the media is convinced it's
not a good thing capitalism is a great
thing entrepreneurship is a great thing
free enterprise is a great thing they
don't go without each other they need
all the each other for it to be
effective
so I love wearing these shirts that says
I love capitalism or enjoy capitalism or
I'm an entrepreneur and I'll walk around
in the airport and some hundreds of
people will come up to me the same and
I'm an entrepreneur as well man I'm an
entrepreneur as well so from the moment
we launch the shirt first time I wore it
and an exiting body said how can I get
the shirt so then we had our guys design
the shoe
so other people can get it as well I
don't know what surprise funny things
like 22 23 24 bucks all these different
sizes and people are ordered people
ordering hundreds all over the world are
be a world are being ordered right now
and there weren't it proudly so here's
what I want to do you order your shirt
I'm an entrepreneur with the value tamer
logo you're going to hear a lot about
the slogan here pretty soon
or you ordered a shirt I love capitals
I'm gonna enjoy capitals and we're quit
quitting order your shirt put it on take
a picture hashtag value taming on
Instagram or put it on Facebook message
us we can do some special with those
pictures that you take with the shirt so
make sure you take those pics and by the
way they can order their shirts on value
taemin store.com I'm going to put the
value Tama store.com here Mario let's
put an annotation link on here and if
you don't see the link here you can
click on the bottom description if you
don't see just go type it on your URL
value Tama store calm and throw me my
favorite pillow baby and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel yet please do
so we are so close to 100,000 we are so
close to a hundred thousand and so many
of your helping contributing sharing all
this other stuff that you're doing
thank you for everyone sup I feel this
channel has some of the most loyal
dedicated serious fans out there for
entrepreneurship I keep trying to bring
content you that's just not just about
motivation it's about inspiration it's
about how to unless ins where you can
actually apply in your business and
start getting results and if you're
somebody I watches videos you're proud
entrepreneur share this message with
everybody else who is also an
entrepreneur or invite other people are
thinking about entrepreneurship but
they're afraid they need to watch a
video like this so with that being said
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
you